hello friends i'm alana um i you know
did some work took a lunch break and
then came back and saw
the internet blowing up about something
called gamergirl which as
uh rod slasher has tweeted uh basically
the official playstation account
released a trailer for this game and
then really quickly
deleted it um i haven't watched this but
i imagine this is going to be some kind
of disaster it seems like it's called
game ago
so let's do it peggy 18.
whales interactive let's look that up
afterwards
hey everybody
okay cool water time break time
that uh junk has been taking out my
stream
oh come on
oh my god
moderate what do i do like do answers oh
my god this is so creepy
we should go for drinks after yeah maybe
yeah i know what do you guys think
you're streaming again what's it to you
oh my god
so i guess the idea is like you go from
being like a viewer to a moderator to
like
dating this girl this is a [ __ ]
nightmare
i'm just gonna make sure he's okay
i mean if they make it like a
mechanically interesting game the
concept like of it being playable
thank you oh my god
all platforms september 2020 i wonder if
they're still releasing it so what is it
it was wales interactive let's look that
up
whales interactive here we go oh they
follow me hi
you tweeted anything about here we go
gamergirl is about the impact user
comments and actions have on the stream
is mental health and
well-being the reason why fmv future
created the game was to raise the issue
of the toxic environment which can often
appear online behind the anonymity of a
username
okay
without giving away too much gamergirl
is an empowering story of a female
streamer who with the help of her
moderator friend
battles the trolls and overcomes the
toxic characters in our stream i mean
it's not like
talking about internet harassment in an
interesting way
um and even making a video game out of
it
is something that i'm against people
doing um
it is very specifically the
having it be like someone behind a
keyboard who's like saving this girl and
spying on her life that i find
to be really [ __ ] up uh
game ago was co-written by alexander
burton the lead actress who improvised
the entire script the research into the
streaming content of game of thrones
took
four years in the dev team at fmv future
interview dozens of female streamers
most of whom experienced abuse of
various kinds online some have even
shared their experiences during
interviews within the game
i mean it's not like that stuff doesn't
happen everyone gets gets harassed i
mean i recently had this guy who would
like
just constantly make accounts he
probably made like hundreds of new
accounts to just harass me all day every
day
like a thousand comments um from this
same dude that i don't know and it's so
wild when that [ __ ] happens because
you're like
i don't know you this hate doesn't exist
in my head like this is nothing to me
but to you it's like your whole life
like this dude was so obsessed about
it i mean i'll probably watch this video
you're just so obsessed about constantly
like
harassing me on work streams like at my
colleagues like
every like youtube video i ever make
where he would just like
interact with like it was so obsessive
it's it's sometimes you just think about
it in a way that's like well look i'm
not a person who's ever left a mean
comment on youtube
i don't think i know anyone who has done
that so like what do i [ __ ] care
you're probably a piece of [ __ ] but when
you have any large audience
there has to be at least one percent of
people who are
either mentally unstable in a really
negatively
um impactful way or
just very very different to you or
someone that you wouldn't like anyway
it's kind of unavoidable i think
um and what they're saying here is fine
and again the interactivity of it is
interesting but
it's the uh the moderator hero [ __ ] that
i have a problem with if you were
playing as the girl that might be
more interesting see some of the replies
i'm sorry but this is not the message
you sent out within this game it feels
like you're making fun of the sexual
harassment the female content creators
experience on a daily basis that i know
the full game will entail but the trade
trailer did not make it seem positive
trailer misses the mark by a light year
if it's meant to advertise a game to
raise awareness yeah it definitely
doesn't seem to do that that's what i
feel like
it feels like you're fetishizing and
being in control of a female streamer
100
yeah and the particular choice of
outfits and the bad boyfriend is like so
much like
oh you could be the guy to save her oh
which is just [ __ ] weird
maybe it's a bad trailer
i don't know it seems [ __ ] strange
though
i've been playing games for over 30
years and this is the single most
uncomfortable
i have ever felt in viewing any game
footage seriously these experiences
don't make a good game not when too many
of the people behind
the stories genuinely fears will happen
to them that's also true i had to go to
the cops a bunch
last year because of something that
happened i don't i would never [ __ ]
play this that's for sure
i like look i'm not in the the camp of
like i hate this
i don't find this [ __ ] revolting i
don't feel that way
i also don't agree with this online
abuse is real and still happening every
day and should not be portrayed
as a fun quirky idea by a video game i
do think that you can tackle
really serious themes in video games
it's like the weird [ __ ]
the concept of the person who's
moderating like saving her life and like
her having a shitty boyfriend as a part
that i'm like oh
nope nope nope nope wow that's
hey it's interesting
it's interesting you you did
something damn
uh yeah i don't think that it will lead
to real world violence or anything but
jesus
what a some of these takes are very
intense
but i guess i should expect that on the
internet
oh my god
imagine that oh god for the record
you you can be a female gamer and still
wear skimpy clothing that doesn't
automatically make someone
not a female gamer just because you
don't do it
and other people do doesn't make them
doesn't make you any better than them
that's not a good take either come on
now come on now
[Music]
the title is clickbait and the use is
abusive i don't know about that
yeah no the part that gets me about this
is is the uh
the fetishy side of the moderator like
getting close to the girl and starting
to text her and like getting involved
with her boyfriend [ __ ]
i don't want any of that
that's a nope from me